Today, we'll learn about day and night.
When we see the Sun is shining in the sky, it is day.
And when we don't, it's night.
So the question is why is the Sun in the sky seen at some times and not at others.
We see that the Sun seems to move across the sky starting in the east in the morning.
Then moves toward the south at noon and then finally toward the west as the day ends.
Hmm, how does this happen?
Let's see why we have days and nights.
Let's assume this globe is our Earth and this lamp is the Sun.
Now, look closely.
The light is shining only on one side.
This is day.
Now, look at the other part and you can see it's dark.
This is night.
When the Earth rotates, day changes to night and night changes to day.
That's how the rotation of the Earth causes day and night.
Pretty cool.